[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want and
we have Stacy back and thank you to our
sponsor native deodorant native creates
simple safe and effective products that
people use in their bathroom everyday
native deodorant is formulated without
aluminum parabens in town and uses
ingredients found in nature such as
coconut oil shea butter and tapioca
starch and native has never ever tested
on animals and that's very awesome
because making the switch to
aluminum-free deodorant does not mean
having a sacrifice on product
performance native has over nine
thousand five star reviews it comes in a
variety of cents for men and women such
as coconut and vanilla lavender and rose
and cucumber and mint
they also have an unscented formula and
a baking soda free formula for those
with sensitivities for 20% off your
first purchase visit native deodorant
calm and use the promo code OTR during
checkout there is no risk to try native
offers free shipping as well as returns
and exchanges in the USA if you don't
know where that is you need go back to
school again for 20% off your first
purchase visit native deodorant calm and
use promo code oh t r during checkout
thank you and native whoa this is
actually really good smells really good
it's good enough to eat a new boyfriend
you know what boyfriends are trying
still smells like this is cute here to
close a new boyfriend huh oh my god keep
it how long you guys been together
Oh year in so change that fools talk huh
she's really tall he's like 6-3
it's a customer Mexican when you
automatically speak to Mexicans just
come down because he speaks like that
regularly even when you're not around
yeah he's really talking have any shared
hobbies yeah you please volleyball and I
play volleyball so I just played
volleyball at the barbel birthday how
did you do we were [ __ ] good I don't
even know how good that was
did you guys able actually like like
pass set here or he's just like hey it's
dig okay okay
spikes like is it at all people sport we
played three on three and I didn't
realize how fun it was good I think with
that like so usually our pickup game is
basketball but then it's hard to include
everyone because everyone has different
skill levels and sometimes half the
people on this side of the court the
other half are on that side just running
around what I really like about
volleyball is it's almost part of the
game to have to pass three times before
it gets across so it's not almost it's
literally the game it is beginner and
it's so everyone feels way more included
even the guy that's not athletic at all
he still has to get in yeah so I felt
like way more bond in and every time you
score a point you have to stop each
other's ass you know since the a
slapping point that was his favorite
coaches taught us all that first yeah
before that's why they wear those tiny
shorts the Jaeger that's an awesome part
of volleyball do the guys we're tiny
shorts - no no I've never seen a guys
volleyball game same length did you play
beach volleyball or beach so those funds
make it like dive into the sand Dan you
guys we're doing the mole yeah we can do
everything like so like I'm not scared
of getting hurt or anything super fun
yeah I love it when do you play that
through a man uh so we go to open gym
every once in a while he plays way more
than I do because he's still actively
place I played such a long time ago and
the level in which you place out is
better than me so sometimes I'm like I
just let you go because I don't wanna
get my ass you play with your nails and
they don't [ __ ] them so I got super
competitive so they only really pop off
is my foot if I go up to block and like
one time I went up to block in my nail
flew in all things
yeah but I forget so um it's a good
thing they're acrylic cuz yeah chiral
recently I broke my natural nail I mean
they hurt to vision because they like
fly with your regular now yeah but if I
have them on I just won't walk to block
but I could still pass in hey I couldn't
pass cuz my [ __ ] likes ya I mean unless
it like actually hits me no but do it
has to be like so certain you know but
yeah he plays way more than I do I'm
taking away more credit than I deserve I
haven't played in a minute is that your
favorite sport bali-ba to play to watch
to play to play yeah to watch I probably
like like track I love track gymnastics
to watch track yeah dude it's [ __ ]
intense pretty watch isn't it ten-second
limpet you same birthday
yeah dude like a sprint I feel like it's
so fun to watch longer than they I know
dude
when you bet on that it's like a quick
bet you like too bad who's gonna you
know it is it's like racehorses yeah
yeah yeah there's if there's like nine
black guys on one white guy which guy do
you bet on I mean depends on their staff
friendly questions yeah the one with the
last name bolt yes
whichever one it is okay or - just
kidding that's not an actual runner it's
a character from The Incredible oh I
feel like I got defensive you guys just
looking at you no one knows that they
got a kid what happened I was thinking
of that dog were named bull Oh
he watches dumb stuff still he does not
be Incredibles know what is this this is
a mop bucket what kind of contact
yes he's watching stuff that goes a is
for Apple
uh Apple right cuz it's like teaching
him how to sound out the letters and
then he'll go like B is for ball
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that's awesome what did you come out
with look at it 30 yeah so it's like
bracelets necklaces
we're like a sparkly one which one's on
your hand oh this one yes so this
sparkly wants like are the ones that
flew super fast so I'm like alright
that's the one I need to get um so like
to unhook your like go down oh yeah so
that's how long does it take before it
turns green what do this one doesn't
turn green green
you could always keep it on but yes so
it's like one of my passions jewelry
always has been and I was I yeah no see
nice
everything has a black dot to it no not
everything and it's heavy - why are you
charging this much I would pay double
date how much is the necklace yeah how
much is it this one I think was $24.99
what I should have been like 55 girl so
I don't know [ __ ] I mean okay you know
what
don't look at the website to like just
don't--i it was actually $60 and it was
hella cheap yes it is it plated in like
gold no it's um what does it call steel
stainless steel okay yeah so that was
like super important to me because I
always wear jewelry and I hate to take
it off because I have nails so it's like
a hassle to have to take it on and off
so I always keep my jewelry on all the
Chinese shower yeah so that was
important to me so yeah cuz I don't know
Nordstrom and stuff and it'll be like
minimum fifty five bucks and it starts
turning green yeah Nordstrom is like a
pretty legit same with like anthropology
and free people unlike their [ __ ] I
thought spend anymore would would make
it like last longer their [ __ ] goes
green so fast and I hate jewelry
goes green because I'm well you could
just get that of forever21 for like six
bucks you know you shouldn't go crazy
like what how is this why yeah so cheap
yeah well affordable safe it sounds very
portable the price not the quality what
makes you an example going to jewelry so
the actual reason why I decided to do it
was because I was I love love love
jewelry and every so this is Julie's
room seen a lot which is where I'm from
and so it's the style yes when you say
that I guess I've seen a lot see my
penal or seen otherwise
yeah so that's where I'm from and like
the style of it is how its worn over
there you know cuz there's like other
jewelry shops here and Instagram and
stuff but I wanted to bring that back
with me because every time I would go I
would like be like decked out and they
would be like oh my god your stuff so
cute so I was like well let me bring a
piece of it to you guys and you know I
feel like you guys can have a piece of
me and where I'm from by wearing it you
know
what's similar about it what's seen alot
about it it's just the way it style I
mean it's not like this necklace is like
siano on it but the jewelry that the
women wear over there is like this you
know so it's like um what do you call it
the pendants are just circle well no
it's just like it's more classy you know
what I mean the way I see it like at
least it's just like more stylish and
like elegant in a way rather than like
like just a narrow or no shade anyone
who wears arrows but you know what I
mean it's just I don't know like more
thin and yeah like delicate yeah I guess
elegant is the word I would use
yeah how do you sell again you wouldn't
use how do you say elegant Oh God he was
almost right and elegant you said the
hell ahead yeah yeah plug it what's the
cause oh so you guys can find out
apodaca jewel on instagram my last name
ie bohdanka
apoE you buy it I put gah I understand
you yeah so another websites the same
thing epoca Joel calm if you guys yeah a
lot of the stuff sold out right now
because people like to again look good
I thought to Layton God dude how long
did it take you to from creative concept
to product so I actually had that name I
like made sure was a vowel which is my
last name so I figure it would be um
over a year ago and I just made the
Instagram and I didn't tell anyone and I
just had it in my bio and it was so cute
because I thought like people would go
to my Instagram and like click and
follow it like before they knew what it
was which I thought was really cool
shout out to those with it and like it
just started growing like that and for a
while I was like no jewelry no one's
gonna like like it and stuff like I'm
like the only one who likes jewelry you
know I just figure like I I guess
because I came from the fitness
background in this girl so I was like
they probably don't care for it but I
feel like I don't have bad taste to use
of that I feel like also like maybe I've
grown enough out of fitness where I'm
like well let me just try it you know
like let me invest into it and if it
works out cool and if not then it's fine
like it wasn't like a big huge
investment to me but now that I see that
people really really like that I'm like
alright let's invest more into it I like
jewelry too yeah I don't do men's
jewelry even though there's like I like
women's jewelry too
I'll bring you some yeah you are really
good I just buy it to look at it yeah
yeah you can gift it for your new ladies
no mine no I I got into jewelry design
because I'm like into like just buying
and selling gold yeah and in like it's
it's interesting how that whole world
works and it's like holds so much value
but also a lot of people get tricked
because well I don't know like people
people go to the mall and then they buy
a 14-karat gold item for like 800 times
the price when you can get the same 14
karat gold ring anywhere else like you
could probably go to downtown or
whatever or something no they just mark
it up like crazy at the mall cuz people
don't know because I know sterling
silver there's something to do with the
taxes which is why you could get it
cheaper in like Hawaii or something
because it's you don't talk about well
Hawaii just has a really low
yeah they have a really little sales tax
for anything so you people like I don't
know I don't know about silver that much
I'm more like I know more about gold do
you buy a lot of golden now I uh like
and down I get gold bars and stuff and
like i buy and sell we you get gold bars
yeah investing it depends on the market
price so they're like this size stacking
like gold bars and it's what they're
called bullion still but it's like this
mom's like it's like uh an Beast a mint
oh that's cool though yeah I've seen
your gold collection but I was like I
never saw a gold bar yeah yeah the gold
bars like this I had a couple of them
but it's called like a troy ounce which
is different from a regular ounce it's
it weighs a little bit different but
yeah right now I think it's about a
thousand five hundred for one yeah but
but that's a good way to save your money
right because it will only increase over
time yeah I was looking into it like I
was like man I need to start investing
in something I don't know where the [ __ ]
to start and I was thinking about
getting gold bars but I never knew how
to make sure it was good it was real it
was like the quality or whatever you
know so what thing I found out you do it
yeah it's pretty simple but I think
there's other better things to invest in
I just get it because it's another way
of like if [ __ ] goes down you have it
yeah because it's like I got a run to a
different country
mm-hm I'm gonna I don't know I just have
different scenarios right so like like
you ever have to flee the country ya
never know the best thing like a regular
human being but then there's also
investing like if [ __ ] hits the fan and
I need to run yeah or just in general
like what if some [ __ ] goes down in
America any stuff to run yeah like we
have natural disasters right like think
about all the people that went through
the hurricane and they were just stuck
in their city for a minute and they
didn't know what the hell to do or
whatever right so you just hear all
these stories so I just like to have
like I'm a doomsday prepper in my head
so then you have a bag that's ready to
rock like a like that I should have one
but I don't know
what are you prepping for that cuz I
could literally just grab my gold my
cash and my gun and I'm ready to go so
if there was a flood I feel like that
would be the first thing to sink to the
bottom because you a loser to me no I
think we'll deal with the earthquake
before we deal with the flood in LA yeah
it's all your gold can collection like
heavy you just know it's literally like
if you have a case like that you could
probably fit about 50 to $100,000 worth
of gold easily I just want you to sit
under a rainbow with your bag of gold
just agree yeah and then so I think gold
is something that works all over the
world yeah you could go to any country
and you can cash that in with and it's
in it's good yeah yeah but what if
something happens to the banks what if
something happens oh it's a like kidney
then go right back to sell a kidney
that's crazy yeah I'm sure there's some
maybe one of your followers did you know
that the reason why pimps have a lot of
gold is because the cops can't take that
from them why no they can't because it's
a law where like it's basically
considered your possession and your and
not cash right so it's like your your
jewels like gold chains is that what
rappers do a - I don't know about
rappers but like the history behind the
whole pimp stuff is they can use that
money for bail if they get in trouble
yeah but then they can if they have cash
on them the cops could take that because
they're like oh that's you know evidence
and all this other stuff but they can
use those like gold chains as bail money
yeah yeah isn't that crazy smart yeah
that's really smart I mean definitely
pimps are bad but that is more no cuz I
was just talking to our one of our cop
buddies this past weekend and then he
was telling me about like how they put
like you see quick he's been putting
away these criminals and then I'll just
asking about how bail works and he's
like bails not as easy as it seems
because even though you only have to put
like 10 or 20% down with the bail is you
have to validate where you get your
money from so if you're a criminal
you don't really have paper trail so you
it's still kind of hard to get
but if you have gold you but well I sold
five of my necklaces that's what my
money came from yeah yeah yeah whatever
we use bail bonds people I think that's
different I'm not too familiar with that
but he was just telling me about the
super high-profile guy that he just
locked up and this guy's bail was a
million so I think he has to pay the
court two hundred thousand and then I'm
like but for someone at his level isn't
that easy for him to get can he just
skip town
and then here's I walk she has like 48
hours to validate what the $200,000 came
from and that's probably gonna be pretty
hard for this guy damn that's crazy
that's a whole different world yeah yeah
for sure okay if you could press a
button and not exist anymore like would
you do it why would you want to commit
suicide no no you don't commit suicide
it's just like you never ever existed
yes and what would where would you go uh
you back to where your soul came from
but then you are aware and your soul
that sounds like suicide but no but no
cuz suicide affects everyone around you
like like one it's a wonderful life type
[ __ ] I wanna burn and make other people
go away yeah cuz it's like where do I go
do I get to know what happened without
me you know like yeah yeah you what
happen with all that yeah it's like it's
like it's a wonderful life can you come
back like in their mind like you go back
it's better down there no because I feel
like taking back that button when I die
I'm gonna go there anyway so I get to
explore this life and then when I die
I'll go back okay so like you know in
Super Mario sometimes you're like [ __ ]
I'm gonna lose like if you're playing
like Super Mario Kart and then like the
blue shell hits you like right at the
end so does I just restart the [ __ ]
race you know like I'm just like I just
I'm not gonna win the marathon now so
I'm just gonna restart I rather have
like click like the remote because I
think and I have been playing recently
because he got the Super Nintendo like
old-school one and then now he has this
feature where you could pause and then
rewind back to like right before you
died or right before you messed up on
something yeah
so we you just keep saying like rewind
time and like instead of actually
finishing the whole thing or like dying
middle of it so much in life was like
that rewind things and like constantly
just trying to do over and do them
though like mine [ __ ] me cuz imagine
how everything would be like you would
just be rewinding and rewinding everyone
you'd probably like wouldn't know how
much OCD f no people with OCD keep like
never progress yeah I'd rather just stay
there yeah you have to go through
hardship I mean I press fast-forward way
more than I rewind yeah [ __ ] yeah
okay [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I
would do that
[Music]